Speaker 1: Yes, Donald Trump is getting arrested
later. But we start today with economic news.
We'll get to this, the Trump stuff. We'll have
time to discuss it tomorrow. Let's start with
economic news. Inflation has now dropped to its
lowest point in two years. And as you all know,
I don't like to play politics with these economic
indicators. I don't play politics with debt and
deficit. We have to look at it for what it is. And
if you do that, you will then have no choice but
to laugh at the way that Fox News covered this.
Yahoo Finance reports Inflation. Consumer prices
in May rose at slowest annual rate since April
of 2021. That's, in fact, more than two years.
It's 25, almost 26 months. The Consumer Price
Index revealed headline inflation rose 0.1%
over the last month and 4% over the prior year
in May, a slowdown from April 0.4%, month over
month increase and 4.9% annual gain. Both measures
roughly in line with economists forecasts. So we
have a chart that you can see and of course you
see this massive inflation spike that started
right when COVID started. Essentially,
it has now come down to levels that
are still higher than what the U.S. has
seen, better equivalent to what we saw
in 2011, lower than what we saw during the
recession in 2008, similar to numbers we
had in 2006, similar to numbers in 2001, lower the
numbers in 91. So you start to see that we are now
in an inflation range that is a little bit higher
than what we have historically said is the target,
but are very reasonable inflation numbers. Is this
a surprise? It is not. I don't have any special
predictive ability, but anybody paying attention
to the trends. We saw an increase in the rate
of inflation. We saw a decrease in the increase
of that rate. And then the next thing you would
expect is an actual decrease. My thought was that
by the end of this summer we would be somewhere in
the 4 to 5 range. We may even once we get June's
numbers in July or July's numbers in August,
we may actually see inflation down into the high
threes, which is even lower than I thought it
might be, or it might stay level right around this
4%. Important to understand a couple of different
things, and I always explain these things. Number
one, when people see the number 4%, very often
they think prices went up 4% in May. They did not.
4% is the inflation over the last 12 months. And
what happens when you get a new month's worth of
data is that in that year indicator, you drop that
13 month ago number and you add the latest one.
So let me give you an example. The number we got
last month in May. Told us what was inflation from
April 22 to April 23. Now that we have the main
numbers, we update the 12 month indicator and we
now know what was inflation from May 22 to May 23,
it's a trailing 12 month indicator. Number
two, many people aren't aware that based on the
standards that we have for our economies and how
we think about the economy, the goal is roughly 2
to 3% inflation. Now, you might say, David, why?
Why would we want inflation? And it's important
to understand this. You can critique it by saying
this is not sustainable long term as an economy
because we can't have indefinite growth, which I
would engage with you on. But the reason that a
little bit of inflation is considered good is if
you have too much inflation, as we understand life
becomes unaffordable for people. It can cause
spending to stop because people can't afford
things and it can cause a recession. That's if
we have too much inflation. You might say, Well,
but wouldn't deflation be good then? Prices going
down sounds good. People can afford things. If you
start seeing deflation where things get cheaper.
It also causes people not to spend and businesses
not to invest. Why would that be? If you expect
that things will be cheaper in the future,
either as an individual consumer thinking about
buying a car or as a business thinking about
doing an expansion, building a new warehouse,
or whatever the case may be. If you think it
will be cheaper in the future, you would wait.
That waiting is a decline in economic activity,
which then trickles down and can lead to layoffs.
And okay, so that's what we call a deflationary
spiral. That's why a little bit of inflation is
considered good. That little bit of inflation
is what encourages people to buy now rather than
later. But they can still afford right now. And
often a little bit of inflation is in parallel
with wage growth. So that's like the general
economic view. Now, how did Fox News react to
this news? Well, they think there may be too
many jobs. They are pulling the labor shortage
line. This is Maria BARTIROMO and Republican
Congressman Buddy Carter. Just this morning.
Speaker 2: We will also hear from Treasury
Secretary Janet Yellen today, Representative
Earl Buddy Carter. Talk to us about what
you're expecting there, because the treasury
secretary, when we first started seeing this
spike in inflation, says it was transitory.
What are your thoughts on how she'll explain
where we're going from here? Well, I'm.
Speaker 3: Sure she'll make it out to
be is is as good as she can. But at the same
time, we are far from out of trouble here. Yes,
I agree. The Fed may pause next this month and may
not raise interest rates, but that doesn't mean
they're not going to raise them back in July.
We've still got some serious problems in our
economy right now. Labor shortage. Last night.
Speaker 1: I had dinner with a
group of engineers and they were.
Speaker 3: Telling me we need help, we.
Speaker 2: Need engineers. One company said
they had 1700 employees, they'd hire 200 today
if they could find them. We still got high.
Speaker 3: Interest rates in the lobby this
morning. I was talking to a young lady who
said, you know, I wanted to buy a new car,
but I just can't afford it right now.
So high inflation, interest rates,
those are the type of things that.
Speaker 2: We've still got to work on in
this economy. And, you know, Janet Yellen.
Speaker 3: Will paint a pretty picture.
Speaker 1: Yes. All right. These people really are
pathetic. The argument he's making is there are so
many businesses desperate to hire people that it
is a terrible economy. The economy must be doing
terribly because so many businesses are saying,
hey, let's hire because we have demand for our
products and services. Now, let I'll be very clear
with you. Let's talk about labor shortage. A labor
shortage happens when demand for workers
in a particular industry, for example,
exceeds the supply of workers available with the
skills required willing to work at the wage rate
that is being offered. Labor shortages can be a
sign of a good economy or they can be troubling.
Labor shortages can have positive or negative
effects on an economy depending on the type of
labor shortage, the duration, the severity. And
so a labor shortage, even if that's what they
are calling it, is not necessarily a bad thing
for the economy. It might just signal really
strong demand for goods and services. It might
create incentives to innovate and to increase
efficiency. And it might mean that employers
need to offer higher wages. They love talking
about the market and supply of demand, supply
and demand and what a labor shortage may signal,
particularly when you're at full employment,
essentially, is that businesses might need
to pay a little bit more. So just saying labor
shortage isn't an argument and it is certainly
not an argument when people like Maria BARTIROMO
And what was this guy's name? Buddy Carter,
are the ones making that argument. Understand?
That there is no economic indicator right now
that signals a weak economy. There is just
none. And we're going to continue covering that.